[Musique]
c'est une annonce qui a fait le tour du
monde hier et qui a fait grimper en
flèche les bourses financières 16 du
laboratoire américain pfizer qui annonce
avoir réalisé un vaccin contre le coc
vite 19 efficace à 90%
nous n'avons aucune publication
scientifique qui permettent de confirmer
ou d'infirmer ces résultats j'ai du mal
à me positionner définitivement par
rapport à cette annonce parce que je
n'ai pas de données scientifiques
fiables qui me permettent d'analyser ces
résultats des accords ont donc également
été signés avec d'autres laboratoires
comme pfizer notamment astrazeneca
sanofi et curé vac soit jusqu'à 1
milliard 700 5 millions de doses déjà
commandé par les européens
38% des français disent qu'il se ferait
vacciner dans les trois mois après la
commercialisation de cet éventuel vaccin
c'est très bas en fait dans la liste des
pays où on est on est quasiment tout en
bas et c'est d'ailleurs un paradoxe
parce que les français soutiennent le
confinement mais ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner
donc c'est j'y vois quand même une
contradiction ils veulent se protéger du
vaccin en restant à la maison mais pas
en se vaccinant depuis un bon petit
moment
tout le monde semble savoir ce qu'il
faudrait à faire et avoir fait alors
qu'ils n'ont pas levé le petit doigt
pour quoi que ce soit ça suffit ça va
quoi personne ne sait rien
voilà faut être clair personne n'ose le
dire mais personne ne sait rien vraiment
une question cruciale reste en suspens
combien coûtera ce fameux vaccin pour
l'instant le laboratoire table sur un
tarif de 20 à 35 euros la dose environ
et il en faudra deux par personne
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
préconise plutôt 8 euros 50 pour que le
vaccin ne soit pas réservée qu'aux pays
riches
depuis l'annnonce de confinement les
sports nautiques vous le savez sont
interdits et même si vous avez la chance
de vivre à moins d'un km de la plage
mais le week-end dernier dans le
finistère certains amateurs de surf
avait pourtant trouvé une parade se
situe suis ont présenté aux jardins dans
certificat médical sur leur médecin le
surf était indispensable à je cite leur
bonne santé psychologique ça vaut pour
beaucoup ce poste alors les gendarmes
ont fait preuve de clémence
pas de verbalisation mais un simple
rappel à l'ordre des commerçants de
boulogne-sur-mer ont publié sur
les réseaux sociaux des photos de nus
très décent parce qu'il dit voilà tant
qu'à être mis à poil par gouvernement
autant le faire nous mêmes
voilà donc ils se il se rebelle comme
ils peuvent
alors on nous dit clic comment ça
s'appelle clic clic
ali collecte click and collect bref la
guerre au nom mais maintenant on va
parler anglais mais qu'est ce que c'est
mais c'est pas c'est pas anodin
click and collect braille friday c'est
ridicule pourquoi c'est ridicule parce
que derrière ces amazones et ça personne
ne le dit c'est à dire rv dans général
de gaulle est ce que le général de
gaulle aurait livré la france à amazon
[Applaudissements]
mais voyez la fermeture des librairies
pour revenir là dessus c'est tellement
choquant par rapport à l'est à l'aco
signal sur la culture non alors on voit
les gens vers netflix vers les verts des
majors américaines encore à ségolène
royal plus quoi garder les faits à
brutus et vous fumez restez chez vous et
c'est tout la pose de ce grain
d'ailleurs je vous cache pas que c'est
un de mes livres préférés a alors je me
permets d'émettre un léger doute là
dessus j'ai quand même la forte
impression qu'elle a découvert le booker
en direct nue et dans un nuage
paraissait contempler avec conques uspi
aucune piste ans puissance pardon tu
sais moi en même temps le world il
aurait souligné en rouge ça c'est pas
possible en l'école à la maison a eu un
effet négatif pour les élèves de cp leur
niveau en français a baissé de deux
points par rapport à l'an dernier
en mathématiques les élèves sont
également moins bon leur niveau a baissé
de 0 27 point pour écrire des nombreux
sentiers 1,7 point pour résoudre des
problèmes mais c'est surtout en ce1 que
les retards sont les plus significatifs
il ya plein de trucs qui vont lui aller
mais par contre faut que la grand-mère
elle réussit à habiller sa puissant
quels sacrifices elle réussit fauqué m
coveo
j'aurai quelque chose à vous demander à
c'est vraiment un rêve parce que ça
serait pas aussi que vous passez la
messagerie de mon téléphone messagerie
temps des verbes et celle là on ne
l'avait jamais encore fait vous évaluer
à combien vos chances de gagny cent
mille euros
oui bonjour ici philippe etchebest
vous êtes bien sur le portable de ambre
elle n'est pas disponible parce qu'elle
m'a promis de travailler très très dur
et donc qu'elle vous rappellera plus
tard
merci au revoir j'ai la meilleure
messagerie ever vous allez prendre le
pas ce qu'ils se trouvent
merci merci et merci d'être venu nous
voir avalanche pas où vous allez passer
dans le décor c'est par là elle était
haletant d'alzheimer en 2019 il lui met
le casque avec la musique du lac des
cygnes sur les oreilles et à ce moment
là elles recommencent à faire les gestes
du ballet d'illac dessinant la voir
déployer ses bras bouger bouger ses
doigts une vidéo absolument émouvante
qu'à 5 millions de vues aujourd'hui mais
c'est un métier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il aimait les femmes laides ça
n'intéressait pas les jolies femmes mais
et c'est plutôt ça aimait les femmes ont
d'ailleurs et les bimbos tout ça ça
n'intéressait pas il aimait les femmes
laides et particulièrement les mecs voit
ce qu'il disait les femmes maigres sont
plus nul que les autres bizarre que la
fade c'est bien parce que ce soit à miss
france miss thaïlande mairie de usa
c'est toujours la même image exactement
nous y croyez pas
mais la jalousie me fera toujours mais
quand même terrible à tant qu'il ya des
jaloux c'est bon c'est bon j'ai pas peur
du vide
mais j'ai juste une phobie de la
sensation de vide savez celle qui fait
que dans un ascenseur sur un un dos
d'âne nous avez l'estomac qui vous
remonte à maurice pas l'estomac mois sur
le dos d'âne mais c'est pas grave
chacun a son truc bah moi c'est la sécu
très bien chacun entre qui remontent mes
frais
[Applaudissements]
oh
merci beaucoup et de votre fidélité mes
amis se joignent à moi pour vous et vous
souhaiter une très belle après-midi sur
wii
[Rires]